[Music]
he's an animal
bro you did birds I did some birds fully
loaded there's the sweater yeah that's
right he just asked us to do the cruise
we got to make a decision yeah our
health can handle a cruise with Bert
crisis for four days but it's you know
burnt four days wow I didn't know his
daughter Cruz oh yeah he's an animal we
just oh Red Rocks again like he just
doesn't stop yeah he doesn't stop do you
ever do you stop do you like I need a
are you not going to tour until you have
a full new act no I gotta come up with
stuff by the end of January yeah oh boy
yeah it's tough but I took five months I
did an acting gig in Toronto yeah you're
with it's with the rock right uh Arnold
Schwarzenegger wow Arnold Schwarzenegger
The White Rock
yeah was he cool he was awesome he seems
cool he's really cool yeah Legend yeah
yeah and he's still pretty he was
pre-rock yeah yeah
she like said that she was his trainer
like lied to him just to like talk to
him he's like are you my partner and
he's like she's like yeah it's me she's
like this five foot five he's like okay
let's go he has every woman of uh there
his partner
uh so you just bought an umbrella it's I
mean this is this is not we all have
curly hair this is not curly hair
weather rain because of the rain yeah
yeah
I just I never buy it that's like my
thing I never buy an umbrella me neither
I can't you're true you're a true New
York I just could do this I do one of
those there you go I didn't want to look
like a poodle
do you like coming to New York oh yeah
oh it is on but let's introduce Fortune
her new Netflix special is streaming now
uh good for fortune on Netflix Fortune
themester hey thanks for joining us good
to have you drunk yeah I've been working
on it this is our whiskey Bodega cat we
told you yeah
oh yeah you better believe it and you're
a whiskey Drinker I love whiskey whiskey
bourbon because I'm from the south
that's what we do yeah
yeah rise again oh my God
this is sober Mark I know right that'd
be a good Bluetooth uh tagline it'll
rise again okay Bluetooth Direction Bill
oh is it
uh yeah this is uh we're doing oh Jamie
tell us what we're doing because we've
never done this and our partner uh Chris
Hart our whiskey partner yeah yes has
given us a lot of [ __ ] for never
drinking one of these his favorite
cocktails are whiskey sour this is a
spin on that yeah it's the New York sour
so what the difference is is that it has
a float of dry red wine on top I've
heard about those sweet and the jewelry
we're classy I love it putting some red
wine in that all right I've never tried
this I'm nervous this is exciting not
great red wine on Whiskey it's worth it
it's supposed to be good I'll knock it
until you try it I'm trying but it
sounds like a something a real alcoholic
would do these two together that's how
most good drinks were created that's
true you ran out of ingredients and you
just threw it in yeah let's figure it
out and that's your whiskey what's it
called
Bodega cat whiskey at Bodega
catwhiskey.com is it flying off the
street all right guys y'all are
entrepreneurs oh yeah oh there it is
there it is
yeah
I like my ride gay
it's the old-fashioned your favorite
character uh yeah I'm an old-fashioned
my probably my drink of choice nice but
I like a whiskey sour as well yes you
might be our first lesbian yeah I think
on the show really who else who works
like damn man
all right you know it's like how do you
guys feel I feel good all right yeah
I feel good too
is your other specialist sweet and salty
on Netflix yeah and you had and you did
a half hour yep uh and this is the first
one since sweet and salty yeah Sweden
will come out yeah well at the time it
was like felt like such a bummer I was
like oh I can't go tour but then
everyone was at home so it was nice
because not nice being home because of
the pandemic but the more people watched
it I think because they were of course
chilling at home totally and you went to
the Capitol oh my God
I almost went yeah
you slide those in there
effortlessly that I was almost like yeah
I did like what it's a good gig who
books that
so yeah this is the the follow-up to
sweet and salty nice no fortune cookie
that's what I thought you're gonna go
with fortune cookie I went uh with Good
Fortune that's better I couldn't think
of a name and I was like well I got this
it's hard it's a lot of pressure because
you want the pun kind of right I always
kind of want the pun in there too but
yeah I kept tossing around we would send
possible titles and they're like no uh
so like you know because Netflix has to
agree too do they really yeah they have
to I didn't know that at least where I'm
at they have to they like to sign off I
mean if I really love something I think
I could oh thank you I think if I really
love something you know thank you Jamie
we can make it yeah yeah oh thank you
jam hey Mazel
all right
it tastes like a like a whiskey sangria
yeah yeah that's kind of nice kind of
nice very good yeah that red wine is
what cuts it because it's like there's a
Sweetness in there from the simple syrup
obviously got the sour and then that's
like
I like that yeah you can use like a zimb
but it's better to use dry one it takes
a second but I'm Gro it's growing on me
yeah yeah I think I got too much red
wine me too
here in the picture you want more of
that straight well you know sometimes it
there's egg white used oh
they cut some of the red wine a little
bit I do like the multi-color okay um
but during a podcast we don't we're not
doing egg whites here yeah
yeah I see well that is yeah it is red
one forward
I could switch next round maybe we could
do something else all right well I don't
think Sam likes it I mean it's good but
it's not my favorite whiskey we have all
these ingredients here yeah it's good
well now Christopher Hart's gonna kill
himself
yeah yeah that means we're partnering
with the baby cats you guys drink
because you guys drink different things
that people recommend we'll take we'll
take recommendations yeah yeah we love
rocks I haven't had this before so why
not yeah I know I'm happy we're having
it I had an old-fashioned before the
show yay that's a good drink yeah yeah
it also just do a regular one would not
have the New York a regular whiskey sour
yeah oh that's just not a wine without
the wine I can do this without the wine
mixer all right all right well we'll get
those ready to go
is going down
this might be too delicate of a drink
for you to strong strapping guys yeah
this is I've never been called stronger
strapping in my life so I'll take it
this is uh the sweatshirt's fooling
people
ironically a Burt Chrysler sweatshirt is
making me look better birdie boy yeah
yeah you look pretty yeah
I'll take it man it's a fitted hoodie it
is that's it helps I'm at the HM like if
if the clothes if they just fit well I
don't need anything nice I just want to
fit same yeah same I got short arms too
so I have a weird body so I have to get
everything tailored you did I never
noticed your arms they don't look short
but when you put a new jacket on it yeah
it's flopping off the end like a magnum
yeah you know so why are you delivering
all your dick jokes
really wants me to get on board with
these dick jokes are you a gold star
games I'm a gold star yeah what is gold
star gaming that means I've never slept
with a dude wow nice
this guy yeah that's the gold star
lesbian they've never I've never heard
of that I've never been the wiener why
is it called gold star I don't know
because yeah you're a soldier in the
Army yeah
was there ever a moment where you were
attracted to men or not at all um
unmann attractive for sure but I've I've
just never had that like Vibe you know I
think because I'm around guys a lot with
comedy I have two older brothers so we
immediately everyone has that kind of
bro Vibe like high five thing yeah uh
that we just never it was never that
thing you know I like you're literally
on a drinking podcast we're like yeah
this we're the reason she doesn't like
men yeah these guys like us but no that
makes sense no but it's not like I I'm
not like one of those lesbians that's
like oh God it's gross yeah uh I like
guys a lot but we but like they're not
thinking of me that way and I'm not
thinking of them that way but I do find
men attractive for sure interesting
really wow but the dick is that's where
the rubber meets the road yeah
yeah that thing I don't want I don't
want any part of that the vagina is
objectively better looking than the
penis yeah yeah I think so for sure it
just does my friend growing up was like
I might be gay and we're like oh all
right whatever you know go nuts and then
literally yeah
and then he said he kissed a guy and he
right when he felt the stubble he was
like I'm not gay
yeah sure we were all behind him I mean
not not literally but last last week we
were practicing sometimes we had a sex
uh teacher come in who teaches
cunnilingus we did a bachelor party
episode for Mark uh last week and a
woman who taught us cunnilingus on
melons and Joe DeRosa was watching Mark
and I lick the melons and he said you
know the stubble it makes me it turns me
on a little bit oh yeah it was a weird
moment it wasn't weird I forgot about
that did you guys learn anything we
learned Joe's gay
I think I blocked that out
I learned that that melon was wet as
hell when I was done with it no that's
how you know women are nicer than men
yes they take I know girls who've taken
[ __ ] classes oh yeah but you don't
know do you know any guy who's taking a
we didn't know it existed it was I kind
of was thrown out at Peters our producer
here I was like what do we what's a what
a good bachelor party activities yeah
you know and that was that was one of
them yeah I I think it's great that you
guys wanted to learn some skills yeah
yeah I'm clueless down there yeah
I like to think I could really
yeah yeah I mean you have the equipment
you have more experience with it you
know so yeah I've heard that sucking the
[ __ ] is the move oh but isn't that what
she said or no I thought maybe she
didn't say that but that's what we
should not have we should we should not
have had an instructor come on while we
were getting blackout drunk yeah that's
true that did not stick any of that
stuff I love the melon yeah yeah I guess
yeah that's maybe the clothes will you
slice it in half
you know a Valley now every time you do
that you're like it doesn't taste like
melons
and I hate cantaloupe yeah so yeah that
was tough for me I was licking it I'd
rather lick a stranger's vagina than a
cantaloupe hate cantaloupe
someone's looking A stranger's vagina
could be very nice that's true I think
Caleb least favorite fruit than honeydew
yeah what's the difference between
cantaloupe orange one honeydews oh yeah
you don't like Canada but that's what
you're doing it on I hate it the texture
or the area I like the taste yeah honey
juice is good you get a soft honeydew
that could be a [ __ ] that's a good
mouth there they are right it's a waste
of a melon wait till you're old you'll
like it for some reason oh really it
seems like an elderly food that's true
there's that vagina you're pregnant what
are your Cravings right now uh fruit
definitely fruit oh you're pregnant it's
okay she's drinking this
who's the father
I just find this way to Puerto Rican
women I didn't even sleep with him I
just gave him a hug
just definitely start a third podcast
yeah he did and I had to pay for it yeah
but the honey do it to me honeydew has
no flavors it's like oh if I get a fruit
salad and it's cantaloupe and honeydew
I'm furious yeah honeydew doesn't have a
lot of flavor what do you what are your
like Road snacks
um I mean if it were up to me it'd be
all fatty stuff you know like Doritos
and Snickers but my wife has laid the
hammer down
carrots and hummus oh come on wife uh
cashews things like that that's like my
rider basically yeah I do like chips and
salsa
yeah never gets old love chips and sauce
yeah that's the problem with the rider
though everything you like like I have
beef jerky because growing up we never
had beef jerks it was like 6.99 for a
bag of it yeah so we never had it so I
put on my rider and now I'm like ah
jerky and you but you get tired of it
yeah I I find that you have to switch up
the rider yeah otherwise it gets old my
agent put natural wine in my rider so
natural wine yeah so I don't because we
drank it one night she's like this is
great there should be a new Rider and I
was like yeah sure I was drunk and now
every Club I get there like we have your
natural wine
Diva sorry about that and then if I
don't drink it they're like thanks yeah
a lot of times I'm not even hungry
because you forget that right that
stuff's even gonna be there yeah and
then the person's like I looked
everywhere for these type of cashews or
whatever and you're like I'm not
actually very hungry I'm so sorry yeah
that's true of my openers I try to use
guys who are need to need a gig and they
just pocket all my oh there you go
that's the best when you do gigs and you
get snacks out of it oh yeah we used to
take all Amy's stuff oh
great Amy has good taste in Scotch which
is like lagavolin in there we'd be like
this is like high-end [ __ ] she's doing
those big shows so that's some good uh
treats back there it was just a spread
of like fruit and meats and cheeses and
all that [ __ ] and you know we were young
Comics we were eating Dollar Pizza so
yeah having like a havarti was like whoa
[ __ ] yeah
did you ever hear about I forgot what I
think it was one of the Florida clubs
Eddie Griffin's demands and he gets the
Air Force ones you've heard this right
he needs a new all-white Air Force One
for every show and after every set he
takes them and dumps them in an ice
bucket so no one else can wear them and
then I guess the guy I talked to at the
club who ran the club was like yeah you
know so I told him I was like oh we
couldn't find a fourth pair so oh I'll
go out and get it tomorrow he's like
wait they send you to get it and he was
like yeah and he's like don't don't do
it it's all good and he's like yeah
someone has to get that that didn't
occur to you that someone's days were
yeah when he was face to face with the
person he changed his mind at least like
nuts in a ride or he's like that's fuel
maybe you didn't eat before so I have
like basic [ __ ] to coffee but the wine
thing I get is douchey I I'm a natural
one for sure it's douche that's a bit
dude although if you go to like
Burlington or Portland they're like we
have a special store you know but if
yeah but if you're in like you know
Orlando they're like [ __ ] you
rightfully I deserve it they're like oh
Wine's natural it's grapes what the [ __ ]
that's Florida you were just he was just
in Orlando that's like the toughest fly
I think that's the worst flight because
of all the kids oh right it's all 97
year olds you know on dialysis like you
know a kid yeah who's just screaming the
whole time next year yeah the Disney
ears on and they're running up and down
the aisle it was it was brutal yeah I
stayed in the airport hotel because I
had a show the next day I had to leave
for at like 6 a.m and it was all
Disneyland people yeah coming in I know
and my hotel the walls were papered in I
could hear the kids fighting over some
game and I wanted to be like let the kid
let the other kid play like I was I
wanted to chime in because I heard every
every piece of dialogue it's brutal oh
my god dude what's your favorite cities
to perform in uh love like Nashville
Dallas Chicago oh yeah
um all the major cities yeah well
like uh
great show ing like Mobile Alabama oh
really I had never performed there that
crowd was incredible Chattanooga it's
like that really surprised me like the
people were so pumped Wichita that was a
cool show nice I think places where
entertainment isn't as frequent I mean
they have stuff sure but like uh it's
just it's not like LA or New York where
it's like every second yeah there's like
entertainment every corner someone's
like come into this show right now no
please I don't yeah so it felt it feels
like a more of a a night out I guess you
know for everybody so they're like
pumped and oh yeah plus I started my
tour like June of last summer so people
were just kind of coming back out of
their houses and it was like the energy
was like insane yeah that was like the
coolest getting back on the road the
best it was like emotional yeah crazy I
know I never thought I'd feel that way
touring
this is great he felt like the audience
liked comedy as much as we like it yeah
the first time yeah yeah I always feel
like I'm bothering them yeah because I
barked you know so when you bark you
just assume everyone hates stand up
right because they don't want to come in
you know but then they were like which
club did you I bought for the Village
Lantern not even a club I did that one a
few times but that was I was always I
stayed away from there it was almost too
close to the cellar yeah I wanted I was
more Uptown you know right I that that
room I took some of the worst spots in
my life oh really I mean just
humiliating but you had to bark to get
stage time yeah yeah but it was worth it
it was you know as you weren't doing
mics it was It was kind of worth it yeah
at the time but vanilla you just had to
bring friends to shows they just had to
pay for the shows and they'd let you do
time they have that here too but yeah
but the Barking was it's such a like
dense New York City thing like at least
you spread out for Barbara yeah no one's
walking yeah they're on their cars like
running over you have to go on the 405
and be like with like those cones go to
this show because no one yeah there's no
foot draft yeah I I think it's something
Mark says all the time on this podcast
about how he thinks the best comedy
clubs are uh blue cities and red States
because you get the combination and uh
you know in your special sweet and salty
like you talk about being a progressive
and stuff and but you know you're from
North Carolina yeah do you think that's
that combination makes you like you just
understand the south in a way that yeah
I mean I'm from there my whole family
lives there but you know I'm gay so and
I live in Los Angeles I know Mark is
crazy but uh so I have like this Duality
you know where it's like I I still talk
to them or you know a bunch of friends
from home and have family there so I get
that mentality of what's happened you
know what the south is um you know red
in certain areas and blue in certain
areas but uh you know if my other
extended family members have different
political beliefs I'm not like shutting
it down I don't agree with it but we're
not like not family because suddenly we
don't agree on politics they don't agree
with my stuff I don't agree with theirs
but we find common ground because we're
family yeah especially an Entertainer
and you're good at that I mean that is
like one of the great things about
entertainment is like you know you
become you do it the road is a comic you
find ways to connect with people yeah no
matter what yeah I mean you know I also
don't do politics and stuff in my comedy
because they're way more people that
know what they're talking about more
than me you know so why am I going to
bring that to the table so I do the
thing that I grew up seeing which was
storytelling and that's a big part of
the South that's I was always seeing a
lot of people in my family and other
like crazy neighbors telling stories you
just listen to people talk forever yeah
and I just kind of I kind of picked that
up I think so my stand-up ends up just
being that yeah and I feel like the
South much like new York has a lot of
characters oh yeah my uncle's a [ __ ]
nut bag yeah people that you don't think
are real people yeah and you try to
describe them and you're like I can't
even yes describe you because it makes
it feels so bizarre that it seems like
I'm making up a character of a person I
do that all the time on the road I'll do
like too many Subway characters
they're not gonna believe the shit's
real yeah but they're real they're real
yeah there are some crazy characters
back home and especially growing up and
but anytime I've ever tried to describe
those people we were like I don't know I
can't relate to this story and then I'm
like had to be there I think the people
like Progressive people who have uh
right-wing parents are the most
open-minded people I find because a lot
of people who are super Progressive like
anybody who's Republican you're dead to
me [ __ ] you and you're like you're
Progressive you're open-minded like
you're that's not inclusive right you
know so I think that's those they
literally had to accept people yes
exactly who they disagree with yeah you
know there's something about it like you
know
you go on Twitter and [ __ ] and people
are so divisive and then we go out to
our shows I know there's people that
came to see us but you're like man it's
like people are cool people are chill
I'll even hang out with them after the
show sometimes I was hanging out after
the show in Lexington Kentucky over the
weekend with some people who came out
and they were just really down to earth
yeah human beings no I know but yeah
once you get off the internet yeah but
you connect with people a lot better but
people spend so much time on there yeah
that I think they forget yeah that
people are basically pretty good right
and you know we went to the racetrack in
Kentucky and it was fun it was like
little keenland all the little kids and
their Blazers it's hilarious
it's like the [ __ ] stock market in
Kentucky
you know but it's the redneck uh stock
market you're right that was my opener I
said everyone I'm the worst person here
I'm the owner in like a like a villain
in Django Unchained but they they dress
so well there it's a cool scene I mean
Lexington Kentucky is a great City to
visit you know you know how they go uh
like they always say like oh you're
racist because you had never hung out
with black you weren't exposed to black
people it's the same with political if
you're not exposed to other political
Affiliated people you're gonna just
assume oh they're just like punching
women who are trying to go on a Planned
Parenthood you know it's not all that
it's yeah it's a mix it's some that it's
something but I think everybody has like
a little bit of differences but 86
percent of us are the same we all eat we
[ __ ] we get horny we want to get drunk
we have anxiety our parents are annoying
but then we focus on like oh you you
believe in god you're an idiot you know
and it it's it divides us but that we
have so much more in common that we have
different the 14 is like the extremes on
both sides both can be pretty [ __ ]
annoying oh God yes but uh how good
athletes are your older siblings uh we
all three of us played Sports year round
yeah so we were we were pretty sporty I
was not a much of a swimmer I was
talking about that I know that's it
that's why yeah but my middle brother
was an amazing swimmer like yeah like
Olympic bound at one point wow my oldest
brother was a really great tennis player
and baseball player soccer player I
played soccer basketball softball wow uh
I played tennis and soccer in college I
love sports yeah holy moly tennis is
probably my best sport which is funny
because I don't look like a tennis
player at all but I it's but you can
play I can play when I moved to LA I
played in a league with just like one
other woman and all men yeah yeah I
loved it if I was gonna play pick up a
sport I'd want to pick up tennis yeah
it's a classy game you play forever too
in the pickleball I've not played that
everybody can you pull up I don't even
know what it looks like I know LeBron
James just invested they love people are
obsessed with it it's a wooden pad
smaller court and it does it's loud
though it makes it like
the sound it looks like honestly um and
uh yeah the I don't know what kind of is
it not a wiffle ball I think it is it
it's a wiffle ball with a wooden paddle
I think Ryan Reynolds huh
what's he promoting now I think Aviator
gin no he sold it Oh see it's smaller
the court
weird and it's got that Hollow sound
yeah you can hear the pedal apparently
people have been uh old people building
their own pickleball courts and their
neighbors are getting pissed because
it's so loud ah it is loud yeah because
tennis doesn't have you can hear tennis
but not that same sound wow so it looks
like it's kind of more of a um it's like
Net game yeah it's like ping-pong
I remember in college they had it I
don't know in one of the gyms so I
played a little I was like man this is a
really fun I get why people are into
this big yeah I remember Wall Street
they all played racquetball or squash
they're also very close to each other I
know this game this is for I don't know
people want to stick with tennis yeah
this is for your uh disabled people this
is pathetic it's our own are they no I'm
actually people playing this my gym as
me and a bunch of old people
they all died once Cuomo you know but uh
it's all this is that's what they play
because the ball takes so long to travel
it doesn't look like you can hit it as
hard no that's what I but see that's
what I love about tennis is the speed
you can put on yes an adult sport I love
it when guys serve like 100 something
miles an hour that's my favorite I like
the grunt because then you hit it you
hit back on their speed and then your
ball flies right back at him yeah it
just seems cool like Federer just seems
so cool yeah I really enjoyed his
Farewell and the hand holding with Nadal
yeah awesome really yeah that was such a
hot man he is a hummus I mean like like
are you pull up in the doll he's got to
hit the bad hairline well that's just
happened recently okay but he was having
the arms dude can you just have a big
full head of hair and he might be
thinning out he's probably the best on
the planet I'd say whoa those arms look
at that mean dude but I love seeing them
get so emotional with each other with
Federer retiring they were like yeah
held hands at one point cried together
hardest time I know but they're like
besties in real life apparently it's
like this the number one sport for me
that like I don't seek out but if I come
across on TV yeah I'm glued to the TV
yeah look at that These Guys these guys
like when you see it in person it's so
they're all back they hit so hard oh
look at that oh that'll make you two gay
I don't know what will I want those
jeans off now yes I mean that is a
pretty erotic and a bad boy Jamie what
do you think you're a heterosexual Jamie
what do you think it's just trying too
hard on it I mean wow that's a sexy
photo just like look at it yeah it
really is sexy I've never seen that one
before see that I can find it look at
that wow I mean look he's got it why not
go for it yeah yeah all right I was
wrong all right well yes we're all gay
now
I was worried it was contagious [ __ ]
ing I never knew he did underwear
oh and pulling it down in the back a
little tease there okay let's see
is he a Spaniard he is for today oh nice
I see one of them Spaniards oh yeah look
at the thing about Louisiana comes out
I'm coming up soon there jamo I'm still
nerd I'm still nursing man oh nursing
yeah I'm coming up soon if we keep
looking at these photos
any sport where it's one on one I watch
I I prefer yeah MMA tennis because it's
all on you you know what yeah in team
sports a lot of the time the best player
just gets blamed anyway right so there
is something kind of cool about you're
being like yeah it was my fault exactly
it was my fault yeah it sucked today
it's why improv isn't fun to watch you
know
I want to stand up give me one person up
there fighting for their life yeah but I
do love like I mean I'm such a big
basketball fan I do love that they have
to find ways to work together like the
teamwork who's your team I'm a die hard
Knicks fan Nick's fan yeah okay how
about yeah uh I don't really follow
basketball too much I like the college
sports I mean Carolina what's your
Carolina team UNC oh no that's a nice
team is that the baby blue yep yeah Tar
Heel what the hell is a tar heel
honestly it's probably not great I don't
know let's hope it's not a slur oh I
don't really know what it is
all right
it says over there uh
a rose in here ortario implied that they
worked in a lowly hold on go left a
lowly Trail so it's like a blue collar
person that
um oh Carolina soldiers flipped the
meaning of the term I don't really know
all right so they made it positive
that's the problem with the South you're
like let's not look at this history
like I just like the basketball team but
I don't want to dig too much into it
some one of it will eventually write a
letter and that'll go away oh no
I'm sure Target was derogatory term in
both the race and class
[Music]
oh that's true
hey folks
when you want a smooth high that you
know is made right here in the U.S of a
look no further an ounce of Hope based
out of Memphis Tennessee uh
ounce of Hope is your One-Stop shop for
Delta eight Delta 9 and CBD Edibles oils
and more I use this stuff every night
literally to go to sleep I love it it's
not too high you don't want to go into
some edible coma where you can't see
straight you don't know when you're
gonna die and you're panicking anytime
the phone rings this stuff is just the
right amount it's just perfect it helps
me sleep better harnessing the power of
aquaponics
ounce of Hope is the farm to table brand
for getting high aquaponics combines
fish and plant farming so all the
nutrients released by The Fish make an
extremely healthy plan ah you're getting
high thanks to fish [ __ ] visit
ounceofhope.com and use drunk for 20 off
your first order that's
o-u-n-c-e-o-f-h-o-p-e.com
[Music]
with promo code drunk and start saving
on the best Delta 8 and Delta 9 products
here it is
God Bless America and God bless sheath
underwear let's show Mark we're both
wearing them right now look at that yeah
sheath underwear keeps your balls off
your leg which I mean I love that little
pouch right there oh yeah the idea for
sheath came from its founder U.S army
soldier Robert pattender in his second
tour in Iraq this guy is a [ __ ]
veteran dude oh yeah it worked for him
it's gonna work for you I wear sheath
underwear and they're great I wear them
all it's like my favorite you have your
favorite pairs in the drawer yep I have
a few crappy swiss cheese undies and
then I got my sheath ones that don't
break down they're good support the show
support this awesome veteran-owned
Company Mark tell them how to do it go
to sheathunderwear.com use promo code
drunk to get 20 off your first order
every order comes with cheese 100 money
back guarantee that's
sheathunderwear.com promo code drunk get
sheath underwear and let them support
your balls
uh it's like uh that thing it's like a
bull is that a bull a ramp a ram Ramses
I never I honestly did not know that man
this is kind of a cool name all right
yeah Ramsay Ramsey's it's the ram mascot
all right what's your what's your
routine on the road because you're doing
theaters and you're like you're like
every
every day you're probably going to a
different city right do you do the bus
do you fly what do you do I'm not doing
I didn't do the bus thing because I have
to go back till later in the week
because uh radio yeah do the radio show
with Tom Papa and then I I also do a lot
of acting stuff so that's usually
something I have to fly back for you on
the Mindy show yeah I did Mindy show I
just finished five months in Toronto I
filmed this action show with Arnold
Schwarzenegger
yeah it's cool uh gonna be on Netflix
sometime next year that's huge yeah it's
amazing do you like the show I loved it
I never save a big role on it uh yeah I
mean I mean in every episode
um I'm in the CIA I'm like in the field
guys
what's that do the ear thing yeah we had
the ear things and the weapons and what
what's I mean get down
get to the chopper
what uh that was a trip like shooting
guns beside Arnold that's insane we're
like we're like on Army crawling across
the floor explosions everywhere yeah
I've done something in a while I feel
like well he's never done TV wow this is
his first TV show TV's different though
those guys in that era they I think they
get caught up yeah or at least dead for
a period being like I'm not doing well
they were so movies are so prestigious
big man and all his movies made like a
bazillion dollars totally so yeah so he
but he was like a kid in a candy store
he loved it every day wow the governor
of California and Mr Universe he's done
so much he's cool we went to his house
yeah well what's his house like oh great
I mean all awesome it's all awesome wow
does he have a crazy gym in the house uh
I think it was Jim but he has like a
statue
[Music]
he's a legend dude it was cool I held
the Conan the Barbarian sword yeah
lesbians that's right wow
oh but he's he's like yeah he's like has
so many cool stories like he's friends
with like everybody of course yeah
you're like yeah who wouldn't want to be
friends with Arnold yeah he's been doing
this for decades oh yeah he's a smart
guy yeah if you hear him speaking like
he's a very educated yeah oh God yeah
yeah
so it was it was awesome doing that so
yeah so then I'll go on the road and do
uh I'll do like three or four nights and
then come back and then go back out I'm
finishing up my tour right now uh here
in the Northeast so I'm driving
everything are you enjoying the last few
shows you're like I can do these oh yeah
I'm enjoying working this material until
my special comes out and then you know
now I've got to write a whole new app I
mean that that's where I'm at it's
that's where you're I stress I mean
that's why I'm doing these like weird
yeah smaller cities just because I'm
like let me try to build here inside the
clubs you guys seem to ride a lot like
you guys seem to always be pumping out
materials trying I love it I mean I love
it I mean it's really like Mark and I
have been bouncing bits since we were
like open mikers almost and we all
always talk to each other about yeah so
that's right we would always be like hey
has this been done or is this you know
it's like stuff like just have a friend
to be like is this horrible tell me this
is horrible right uh but then you kind
of yeah I mean I'm more confident now
that I don't feel like I have to do that
as often but we still do it I'll still
text you I still tell you I hit you with
an idea they all run stuff by some
friends who are you who are your comic
friend uh I I talk a lot with Aaron
Foley
yeah yeah she's really good at like I'll
I'll we'll zoom and I'll tell her like a
a story that I'm thinking about and show
she'll kind of like you know say like oh
that's you know there's something there
or like maybe you know expand on that
more or if neither one of us are really
like responding to it like no maybe
we'll just put that back just even
having a friend to like let you go yeah
yes you know and let you talk it out
talk it out I do with Stavros a lot you
know or like uh our friend Ron on
hershberg as well but like just have a
friend to let you talk it out yeah yeah
you find you find the bit yeah sometimes
I'll ask Tom Tom Papa you know he's a
good writer we love him like is there
anything to this premise or whatever
he's got a great laugh too yeah when you
make him laugh you feel good both of you
have a good you're both very positive
and yeah your show is fun to do because
you're both easy yeah we're just like
one of them talk to people about comedy
yeah yeah then you do Jim and Sam and
they're like you [ __ ] homeowner
8 in the morning you can say that to
YouTube
yeah right what uh who are your Comics
growing up they were like that's those
are the people that got me in the
stand-up
oh gal interesting yeah because I
actually started at the Groundlings
I started in sketch and improv hey
yeah so I started more in the sillier
yeah version of Comedy like crazy
characters I still have like so many
characters that no one's ever seen oh
cause I never put them online or
anything I did them at the growlings and
it was like pretty it was like YouTube
was just kind of we're doing a thing and
can we get a can you hum a few bars
I mean it's always like some I like to
play like older women and we were like
you know have short spiky hair or
something very sparkly outfit and you
would dress up have a dress I like lots
of makeup I like just being a someone
totally different than yourself sure how
to play like a lounge singer who's like
talking about a signature cocktail yeah
you know just like crazy people I played
crazy people that's fun very big broad
characters so uh yeah so that's where I
started so SNL was always the thing I
watched every weekend who are your
favorites I mean I was well the first
class was the Sandler
Farley's fade days uh Molly yeah yeah
then it went into Molly Shannon
Will Ferrell that crew they were they
were the most influential yeah because
that was when I was younger and really
watching the show a lot more yeah yeah
so yeah Shannon is so insanely funny so
funny killer in a great serious actor
yeah movie where she uh had cancer yeah
I forgot the name of it but Chris Kelly
wrote it from yeah
um she should have gotten an Oscar for
it she's incredible yeah she's really
good have you heard the rumor about her
what you've heard huh what is it she
banged a guy and the sex was so
passionate that he had a heart attack
this is a Hollywood uh store
is it in her book what probably her book
was very popular yeah I read it I read
an interview with her in the LA times
and it was tragic her life yeah car
accident something like her I wrote her
I wrote her a fan letter as a child when
she was on SNL and she wrote back I
still have the autographed pictures oh
that's cool yeah I wrote Robin Williams
when I was a kid whoa and we got a
letter I found that letter when I was
one he wrote back he wrote back wow yeah
I got like a sign picture did you ever
meet him later in life I met him very
briefly I was doing like a show at the
Meltdown Comics place okay
all right
I'm glad we have a fact Checker though I
guess remember it was two men oh all
right I didn't know that [ __ ] two men to
death there yeah it was so funny oh
there's a plot a curve that's where I
heard it oh okay I thought it was I like
how that stuff catches on though oh yeah
that's uh Richard Gere gerbil that's
right here look it up yeah
um but uh I forgot what you asked I
don't even know what about Robin
Williams yeah yeah that was oh I met him
at Meltdown Comics oh yeah he just like
showed up and was like watching in the
back of the room and I like was leaving
and I saw him uh he left the room and
he's kind of he was very shy yeah I was
like I just love the same a big fan is
like thank you that was very funny like
he's like head down kind of thing
[Laughter]
I mean that was probably like eight
months before he died a year ah you did
it
over the end I did it I met his daughter
um
like a year and a half ago really lovely
two years ago something like that yeah
yeah damn but yeah I loved him I didn't
watch a ton of stand up I watched like
him and Whoopi Goldberg Ellen people
like that show those those big have you
met Ellen uh just from like across the
room oh really yeah but we've never met
it was one of those like hi hi kind of
thing New Orleans she's from North right
yeah she never reps us but just just
that's weird
it's weird to just get away from a
person that famous that's why I met
Larry David just a wave oh yeah no he
was he was like where where Matt is
about that far away and Amy Schumer went
hey this is Mark Larry and he went yeah
I want to like hug him and kiss him on
the lips but you gotta play it cool well
it was right when things were like
opening back up in La after the pandemic
so people were kind of not coming near
each other and we were outside on a
patio of a restaurant and and I really I
noticed my wife was like kind of staring
at somebody and I'm like who's she
staring at I look behind me and that's
Ellen is sitting down and I we make eye
contact and she's like hi she's like I'm
a fan oh wow you left that you left that
part that's the big one oh yeah that was
nice and I was like oh thank you me too
you know we just had that kind of like
um then she dumped hot coffee on the
assistant's head and she was walking
away and that was yeah that was them
yeah if I caught my wife looking at
Ellen I would start looking at Porsche
are they still together yeah Ah that's
impressive that's been a long time yeah
like how many years is that at least 15.
18 or two yeah good for them yeah even
stuck through the you know the bad times
for Ellen when she was wow
everyone now they're trying to drag Bill
Murray that's the new one I know you see
it on Twitter everyone all right they're
like Bill Murray is inappropriate I'm
like so now people are getting canceled
for being mean oh yeah it's Hollywood
it's me baby no that's that's the point
of getting to be a celebrity I've read a
lot of old Hollywood books and like some
of these people I'm like oh [ __ ] they're
lucky they're Dennis Hopper is lucky
he's dead Sinatra all these guys looks
like I can't wait to be mean you gotta
be nice coming up and then once you get
there it's like hey I don't need friends
yeah I'm not sure it was like a manic
depressive who was like awful to people
oh really I didn't know that oh my God I
said to Bob Evans you know he's like get
my wife out of that mover I'll kick your
ass and he called her and he's like if
you do that movie we're getting divorced
and she's like I'm doing the movie and
he sent divorce papers to the to the set
oh wow baby oh yeah and by the way he
was 60 and she was 21.
every day someone not 39 years younger
than you and you won't have these
problems he's like oh
my woman listen
but like dude I mean Mia Pharaoh can you
can you get more opposite than sinach
and then who's the other guy she was
with the famous uh uh conductor right oh
um Philip Glass I know I don't know
uh I mean like she does not have a type
that's all I'm saying yeah for sure
definitely varies
uh oh
Mia Farrow spouses Andre Previn yeah
there we go oh wow she doesn't have a
type that's my oh
[Music]
that was him back in the day to the
right oh okay okay he looks like if
you've mush Sinatra and Woody Allen
together you get him aging does not look
fun
agent is bad it's better for some than
others man it's uh that stopped the
whole pod in the tracks
boy
but she uh no she's beautiful yeah
there you go
um wow I gotta ask you about the
gambling stuff is that right The Gambler
so you said your parents will gamble is
one of your books oh I said um I had
someone in my family not my parents okay
were they were uh had gambling
situation and my uh grandmother paid off
a lot of those debts wow so that didn't
help my family's financial situation it
was like like because my great my
grandfather was a prominent uh
contractor he designed a bunch of houses
and schools and churches in North
Carolina and had and built them he had a
company so he did really well for
himself
um but he died unexpectedly when my mom
was 17 and my grandmother was just like
a housewife and she's like I don't know
what to do yeah so he left a hardware
company this was like preloads and Home
Depot and she it eventually even those
big big stores came in they were going
under but she was too proud to file
bankruptcy it was just a series of Bad
Business things where So eventually all
the money he had left here was totally
gone so when I came when I came through
my family had that like history of
having money but no money and my dad was
like from a trailer park yeah parent
never had a dime a hitchhiked to school
never had a birthday cake a whole
different situation so I I come from
this duet like this weird duality of
like my mom's from like High Society but
no money right but she had it back in
the day and my dad's totally from a
trailer park and you know eating chicken
wings and you know watching NASCARs so
yeah I have this whole weird dual thing
yeah you have so much to pull from I
mean there's so much stuff in your stand
up that I'm like I it felt so like it
feels so real yeah all those stories are
are real it's all basic it's all based
on totally true things I just embellish
everything
yeah yeah
like there's a story in my new
um special where I talk about proposing
to my now wife and like the guy that was
part of the
um the waiter in the story he's like
that stuff happened ish but he's like
two people combined yeah I took traits
from like another person you know what I
mean and so yeah you know if sometimes
will say you made that bit up I'm like I
combined two characters in one it's
different yeah sometimes you just have
to save time yeah you have to edit edit
for the story to make it more
interesting and moving along you're not
telling like a bio I'm not telling a
biography but all the stories are true
it's just you're pulling from different
parts of life yeah I don't even mind
making up because then it also shows
some creativity yeah it's fiction yeah
or you know if somebody's unless the
laugh is like
it's true this happened yeah oh yeah
unless you're doing that but yeah right
of course people make [ __ ] up yeah or
are you like but as long as there's some
truth in there for sure some part of the
story is 100 always going to be
everything I tell is based on something
that happened but it's like how can I
make that how can I because some of my
stories are like eight minutes ten
minutes you're like how can I get people
to sit there and listen to that for
eight minutes you gotta make it more
it's impressive because I'm not Mark and
I aren't really storytellers Mark is
just pure [ __ ] you have some stories no
I do I usually will close each hour on a
story because I just for rhythmically
it's my I think my
structure will get predictable if I
don't mix it up somehow right and also I
usually have one story I don't know
where else to put it except the end
it but true but I'll be watching your
story sometimes and I'm like I'm kind of
like you know I'm watching because I'm
like enjoying it but I'm also watching
like how the [ __ ] she gonna end this
yeah because that's the hardest part of
the story for me yeah that's a
compliment well it really no it really
is and uh
sometimes you watch a story and you're
like I don't I don't know how it's going
to end and the ending is so hard yeah oh
yeah do you usually when you write a bit
do you have the ending you know the
ending or are there times when you're
going along and you're like I gotta
figure out something yeah I I tried on
sweet and salty and good fortune I try
to make both like beginning middle and
like a narrative like we're gonna follow
a timeline but I worked really hard to
try to find what can I pull from the
beginning and bring back at the end ah
the weird fortune that they don't see
coming
uh so that I don't ever no it takes a
while to find that uh whatever that
thing is that brings it back around
that's tough um but I never you know I
only go into every story with like a
sentence like oh that's crazy like uh I
you know proposed to my wife and it went
wrong right well what happened let me
think about it you know that ropes you
right in yeah because I want to hear
what happened yeah exactly so so
everything is like yeah the stuff I'm
trying to work on now I'm like okay I
have like a an idea of what could be an
interesting premise maybe but I don't
know what the story is yet you know oh I
don't envy you guys because this is a
tough you just put out a special both of
you and I'm in that sweet spot where I
got my hour is really cooking it's like
90 done so anything I add is just it's
just land Yap that's extra awesome
that's amazingly fun but editing is
tough and I'm in that point right now
we're like I'll have 50 minutes it's
brand new and I'm like I got 50. it's
not all working but I got 50 to play
with yeah that turns into 37 very
quickly then I get back up to 45. put
them down to 32. it's just a weird dance
where I just keep cutting [ __ ] that's a
good comic yeah because a lot of people
would just stick with their stuff if it
wasn't working well then you kind of cut
the stuff and you're like weird this
isn't a Word document and I guess
that'll either be later in this hour or
it'll be for the next one because I kind
of get rid of stuff of it I can't crack
it we'll revisit it in like a month and
a half with fresh eyes but yeah I mean
when you have a story it's so much I'm
just interested because it is it's just
different than us so I I watch story
Comics like you know someone like you
were like I know Ari shaffir gave me
really good advice once with the story
where he said you know uh end it with
Kobe
I thought it was interesting advice he
said uh
add a line in here and then go back to
that line at the end like add something
so it almost gives you an out if you
can't crack oh interesting Don't Force
the Callback but he's like there's a way
you can add something here yeah you know
like my mom said this you know that's
good and then at the end you go well my
mom didn't think you know something like
that you almost go back to the line that
you had yeah if you can't crack and I
thought that was like Yeah someone who
only tells stories like Ari is yeah it's
interesting that's good yeah huh I heard
some advice was uh
you're telling a story and maybe you're
not mentioning something the whole time
but the audience is kind of thinking it
and then if you say that thing at the
end they're like oh he knows that we
were thinking they kind of they kind of
give you a big pop for that like I have
this whole joke about going to see a see
a Slave movie with my black friend and
it was super awkward and at the end I go
I don't I shouldn't give away my my joke
but at the end I go and that's how I
made slavery about me right now because
they're like oh we kind of thought that
throughout the whole thing like you're
making this like you're the victim right
and then at the end I say that and
they're like all right yeah he's aware
you're self-aware yeah self-aware is is
points it's points true yeah you know
when you go that joke bomb that gets a
huge laugh because they're like oh he
knows a bomb yeah yeah I'd rather them
at least know I'm not doing I know it
I'm not doing well I'm bombing I'm like
I know this is going badly and they're
like all right at least he knows yes
exactly we take some of the like
pressure off right there like okay we're
all we're all on the same page now which
is the essence of Comedy you're
basically saying like I I'm aware of
what's going on yeah yeah I know what
you're thinking yeah well if I'm
following the same uh sort of time line
that I've been doing with the last few
specials the first one was very much
about me like finding myself figuring
out who I was the second one was like
now I'm an adult this is how I am as an
adult it's not necessarily what you
would think and I'm married I'm getting
you know engaged married so now
full-fledged adult and this is what it
is so now I if I'm going from that then
whatever's next would be like what is
the next thing that I'm dealing with as
in you know I'm seven years into a
relationship two years married uh and
kind of digging into that material
that's good and then the audience grows
with you yeah so it's like so every
special mini Evolution right I don't
know bargatzi is similar yeah he does
that I'm doing the thing where I'm
aggressing fully he's special I'm
getting slightly worse yeah well that's
a journey to watching me spiral and it's
fun well I think that this one I want to
bring more of my mom and my wife into
stories together
does your mom like your wife she does
but it was at first like if that feeling
of probably feeling replaced a little
bit wow yeah
yeah more so I think than women but my
parents split when I was 12. so I like
weirdly sort of took on this like
husband role for my mom I was like she
was like my plus one kind of person like
I often times like when I got older I
would come home for Christmas and my
brothers were married with kids and I'd
be the single one so I was like my mom's
companion the like dinner partner the we
went on a cruise together wow yeah like
a five-day Christmas Cruise yeah I mean
I wanted to jump off that yeah yeah
every day I wonder how many people have
just purposely commit suicide I don't
because they were with someone they
couldn't we talked to the chaplain and a
lot of people die on cruises yeah a lot
of old people like yeah like not yeah
they're not jumping off the boat okay
but like they're just old and they die
yeah
he's like constantly giving like laughs
Robert Riley just died on the boat
[Laughter]
Google it yeah
yeah so yeah I think I want to dig in so
when I met my wife I think my mom knew
right away it was a significant person
so she was uh it took her a while to
warm up to her like she was no longer I
like now at a new plus one yeah Jax is
the one that I'm gonna be traveling with
and taking the thing so sometimes might
fly much you come every week what's that
to shows you know not everyone but like
one weekend on one off like that kind of
thing that's a nice balance yeah but my
my mom like she's always like I want to
go to Europe I'm like no you can't no
thank you um so it's so I think there's
got to be some stories in there about
that's great and at navigating that
those relationships I don't know what
those stories are yet welcome I just
have a bit about how my mom would always
say like you know I'd be dating girls my
mom be like I don't like her and I'm
like yeah of course not she's you so I
don't like her and then my dad would
always go I think she's great yeah yeah
yeah Michael always says that uh every
guy she's dated whenever she meets the
mom there's tension yeah it's just it's
instinct or it's yeah well because
normally you do find that with uh yeah
with men introducing their mom to the
new girlfriend it's it's not as common
with women but sure
um yeah that's lucky me yeah like the
heterosexual women get the dad who's
like get away from my daughter yeah
exactly yeah but you but you seem close
with your mom though
yeah so I just my mom's provide a lot of
material over the years so I feel like
there's got to be fun for the Hooters
yeah that was totally true too yeah
um but yeah just kind of navigating the
two of them you know the two strong
women in my life has been a a journey
yeah how did you meet your wife uh at
Chicago Pride oh wow look at that yeah I
never thought you could meet a
significant other in a pride event you
know where everyone's hammered we yeah
ran into each other and kept running
into each other all night just kept you
know
somehow ended up in the same space and
wow
that could be your third special title
hey you keep growing yeah that's not
real is it it's not really a big thing I
didn't think that's like porn for men I
feel like yeah yeah yeah it's more fun
for guys to think about two girls just
you know just rubbing yeah
but it doesn't we don't like women with
strap-ons because then we're like yeah
we're being replaced yeah yes you don't
like that exactly but yeah people are
not really rubbing like that as much
yeah and then every girl I know she's
like I watch lesbian porn over man woman
I've heard that too
I think it's like you know they know
what they're doing gross
balls are gross yeah I've heard a lot of
a lot of my Straight lady friends like
the lesbian porn yeah yeah that's
fascinating I don't know the women like
men I have no idea
[Laughter]
these drinks are going down smooth oh
yeah I'm feeling this it's great
pregnant waiter this is a new thing or a
bartender
[Laughter]
that's uh did you like the that other
one better I do honestly I prefer the I
prefer the whiskey sour sorry sorry
Chris hard sorry Chris you bought me a
sweet rib eye though it doesn't look
nice yeah
it looked it looked classy as hell but I
like my wine and my uh and my whiskey
separate yeah I think so yeah exactly
that's what we learned today we're not
bi no no we tried we tried it as long as
you try open-minded
um oh give me does anyone have a wreck
anyone either of you I got a wreck yeah
what do you got well well uh I try not
to do movies because I feel like I do
movies I'll do so many movies we watch a
lot of movies this movie really just
tickled the taint and it's a horror
slasher movie which is not my favorite
okay but it's so well done scorsese's
raving about this guy Spielberg loves
this guy he's like a new guy on the
scene the movie's called x x pull it up
it's called x
x the letter oh I've not heard of this
it's uh Peter's has seen it it's it's
oh you haven't oh okay it's a throwback
to like like a 24. they make some
interesting they are so good so go to
Rotten Tomatoes what are we looking at
all critics I'm nervous
it kind of shakes up the genre right
there right look at that that's there
you go audience scores 75 I'm shocked
the audience was sometimes the audience
gets it wrong too though but yeah it's
really good it you can't predict it it's
different but it's you think you know it
but you don't know it it's one of those
you're watching with the lady you're in
theaters I watched it on the road with a
comic in a hotel room I was like let's
not get hammered tonight for one night
and we watched a movie and we had a
couple white clothes
but it was it was really good cuties in
it Kid Cudi kills it Kid Cudi and it's a
hell of a premise I don't want to give
anything away all right maybe I'll watch
This I Gotta I got a movie Wreck too
it's an old one though but it's a great
I've Revisited it it's a [ __ ]
Masterpiece it's an old movie it's a
Robert Altman movie It's called
Nashville if you haven't seen it oh I've
not seen it obviously it's a musical
it's it's a brilliant movie I feel
better thank you it really is Keith
Carradine won the Oscar for about oh
sorry for best songs Lily Tomlin was
nominated for it oh man it's a great
[ __ ] movie Altman's a genius I was I
couldn't stop listening to music on the
road this weekend really I don't know
what it's something about being in the
South I'll just start listening to
country music yeah but uh but it's great
music and uh damn it's like it's like
it's like they sing country music yeah
but it's it's it tells a story it's
incredible Altman really was a genius
yeah oh yeah I mean the player is one of
my favorite movies too yes but uh I
gotta re-watch this Nashville was uh
uh my friend Ronan hirschberg's number
one movie of all time wow I think I
think it's one of the best I feel like
there's a lot of movies I need to see
and black was great back in the day Five
Easy Pieces Karen Black yes yes wow all
right I recommend Nashville but going in
it is a musical and it takes Alton
movies take a minute yes yes
let it settle it's not it's the same for
your Tick Tock where you watch it online
it's not yeah you can just rent it okay
Amazon it might be streaming too they
have a high uh an 84 yeah it's a classic
okay it's a classic
they she disappeared forever and they
just found her again oh really yeah she
like went out to the desert or something
I can never tell these people are happy
I think she fell on Hard Times yeah so
man if you look at her resume she was in
so many shiny Nanny Hall yeah she was
olive oil yeah
olive oil wow okay all right Nashville
I'll tell you a Roxanne I used to love
that movie oh yeah that was good yeah no
she was uh I haven't watched any movies
really I don't have any good
recommendations other than I went to
that a lot of people would know this
place but uh I had a sandwich at
Potbelly again
[Music]
it's not bad I don't know
it's actually it's pretty great it's
great and the soups are good too sugar
cookie was phenomenal oh so I think that
not a lot of people know about their
cookie situation the sugar cookies
awesome it's sugar cookies it's a better
Jason's Deli because Jason Deli's fine
this is a it'll kick it up a notch and
you can get like these peppers on the
sandwich that are tasty I love it I
don't know we don't have them in La I
don't think they're in the west coast
but it feels like a Midwest thing yeah I
think it started like in the Chicago
area but I had one recently and I forgot
how much I really like that's a great
wreck I used to always go there when I
played Zanies in Chicago yeah it's like
almost next door to there right yeah
there's one in Midtown not Potbelly so
yeah R.I.P Sarah Dom you used to be
introduced to the interabang we did an
interview in there oh really oh yeah she
was a good good person big comedy and
you can get your sandwiches toasted it
used to be the only Quiznos did that
that's right Quiznos is underrated while
we're on it yeah
Quizno Quiznos ain't bad but I think I
like I prefer Potbelly to quiz probably
okay yeah both no pedophilia oh yeah
maybe it started in Chicago
I remember Italian I tell it a bit of
one of his specials where he said he was
doing a show in the Middle East he goes
I couldn't remember the guy's name it
was something with a lot of cues U's and
Z's I called him Quiznos
uh even mispronounces it
was so stupid but I could kill me I just
picked him walking by a quiz that was me
like that's a funny word
six years I read a joke about that he
showed up at Mark's bachelor party and
he was in such a bad mood we did the
episode here and the tell showed up just
like that he got up at one top point and
was looking around and goes up oh I'm
sorry I'm just looking for some punch
lines oh no
was this the bachelor party he did one
in Florida and I couldn't go because I
went to Dana called the wedding in in
California and then uh
you know a lot of Commerce went there so
we did I we did our own thing here yeah
we did we had a bunch of comics on we
had uh
Joe DeRosa Godfrey Shane Gillis uh yeah
it was what Sean and David tell yeah we
had we did have a male stripper come by
he used to mix it up what's your thing
that with Bert was that what the Florida
one yes yeah that was where a bunch of
you guys were at like a we rented a
giant house he'll be at the bachelor
party not the wedding yeah he flew on a
private jet to come meet us at a time
yeah respect from Italy I'm in a I'm in
a rental car driving around the
Northeast have you done the private jet
for your own gigs no I'm not I'm not
you'll be there soon I'm not quite there
you will be I don't know I've never been
in a private gym yeah I know you guys
have I'm sure yeah as openers uh as
openers you're in one and Epstein's
Island yeah yeah but that was a cool
Island I'm doing it I'm not I'm not in
one for the environment
I feel the same way yeah although I did
hear that Leonardo
he raised a lot of money yeah and a lot
of women
always with the zingers in here yeah
so when you with Chelsea Lately one of
your first like really big breaks
because I remember you really popping
off in that show people that really Josh
Wolf was another one right who looked
really Moshe Kasher Natasha was on
motion
yeah Bobby Lee uh-huh yeah that was my
first big gig I did last coming standing
in 2010 right that was my first TV wow
and then got Chelsea six months later
yeah last comic's a tough experience
yeah yeah I mean I when I was when I did
it they had been off for like two years
and but before they were all like living
in a house together and stuff like very
reality show yeah yeah so I was like I'm
not gonna feel worse I don't know I mean
I was like I cannot live in a house with
a bunch of comics but they're like no we
already do that it's called home yeah
they're like it's just stand up so I
said well I can do stand up I mean I've
not been on TV before what I'm gonna be
picking I remember when Gabriel Iglesias
was on it they like kicked him off for
texting someone while in the house oh
really and I was like you can't text wow
yeah that yeah I I are you supposed to
survive yeah oh yeah there's Lonnie love
God I really look at that I really uh
this bag when TV was fun my wardrobe
show
uh two or two or three three years ago
maybe sad if you're that small the life
expectancy isn't time
is it's really off for me right now
because of the pandemic yeah I can't
remember what was pre-pandemic and I
know it was almost like the last two and
a half have kind of Stood Still do you
think you and your wife got closer
during the pandemic or do you think it
tested some [ __ ] I mean we got married
in the pandemic I think that I think we
we passed the test yeah the other way
well you learned that like no one here
you learned that like that you're kind
of each other's people right you know
like when we couldn't see anybody else
he had to lean on each other what was
your pandemic uh routine what did was
there anything you did like I was a slob
oh my god well because I I didn't
realize how much I'd been hustling yes
exactly like once you shut off well it's
like it's almost like being an athlete
and yeah you don't work out anymore and
you're like well I guess I'm just out of
shape I put on like so much without
getting back into shape is so painful I
mean get back on the stage I was like
this is really I had a stutter when I
first got back on stage oh my God I was
really worried I remember I came to New
York last July and I was did the seller
and I was talking to Comics like oh I
have a stutter right now I don't know
where it came from but then it
eventually just went away that's wild um
but yeah I think because I had
nervousness I don't know if we're just
not talking like that on stage you know
I couldn't like my words just wouldn't
come out it's a muzzle you lose it quick
it's weird how quick stand up yeah so I
think I like was I just didn't realize
that how much I had just been constantly
working constant constant like and you
know it's a business where having one
job's Never Enough you have to have five
six you know whatever and so everything
stopped and for the first time in like
15 years I had nothing to do yes and I
was like well this at first I was like
super bummed out and then I got way too
comfortable I wasn't sweatpants and
flannel and Ugg boots and drinking wine
every night and watching TV I kind of
like started to like it oh my God it got
to a point where we were you know my ex
and I were watching a movie like every
night we're going to the grocery store
we're just like sampling different games
he's like let's try let's see what
twizzler's doing with this like cream
filled flavor here yeah Rolos well
and the I'm actually I would
there was no fomo or whatever right you
know what I mean because it wasn't like
there were other Comics out there doing
a bunch of stuff and you're feeling like
you're lugging behind it was like an
equalizer like we're all at home yeah
can't really do anything and so you you
didn't feel like you were in this Rat
Race that is all like because you know
it's Comics you're always kind of like
oh you're looking at somebody
right I mean isn't that crazy we I still
can't believe we lived through that [ __ ]
I know I know I know it's like been said
to death but I I think about it I'm like
we lived through that's insane that we
just shut down as a country somebody
said it well they said it's the only
time in in hundreds of years that the
whole world had the same problem yeah at
once yeah the whole world the same
problem at the same time that's not true
Kanye West
but uh no uh no that's uh it's crazy
it's uh we all
we all were just stuck we all were at
home we were we were all in like a state
of just no movement yeah for a long
[ __ ] time like I also I also think
like man Zoom cashed in Skype oh my gosh
that could have been Skype yeah yeah the
the the plastic dividers cashed in like
out of the heater outdoor heater for
restaurants a lot of people cleaned up
also if you're a therapist your life
just got so much better oh yeah every
therapist like yeah I live in Miami now
it's all remote I just yeah a lot of
people are still zooming yeah yeah I do
it still yeah we do our radio show I
just do it oh really whoa well you know
you're with a big company Netflix you
know if you're a radio show so they can
just zoom it in where it looks pretty
good actually yeah right on the show but
sometimes Comics a lot at home setup can
be rough but like yeah I mean I do
another podcast uh with a football
player Julian Edelman and we we zoom in
all our guests because they're all
football players or famous people who
don't want to come to the [ __ ] Studio
whether in L.A or something but it
actually looks pretty good because it's
a company if you get a if you get a
legit Engineers on that it's yeah we
have an awesome producer so everyone
sounds fantastic you're like yeah that
you don't miss being in the studio but
it allows Tom and I to go on the road
and do all their stuff do you do
episodes from the road yeah yeah doing
it this week from out here just in my
little home setup you know headphones
Tom is such a chill great dude we love
Tom Papa yeah I look for a flaw with him
I can't find him there's got to be
something something he must have killed
a kid ran over somebody hit the body no
but he's a good dude he did a great he
was great when he did already did this
show too and uh
yeah he's one of those dudes every time
I see him at the seller I'm just like
excited yeah he's got that like because
you know what I think part of it is that
he's an older guy who still drinks yeah
that's nice so I think that's part of it
he's got his like little round hat on oh
yeah he's got a martini and I'm just
like I'm like there's something about
this energy that's almost at a place in
time yeah like you're expecting to be
slapping a secretary's ass while he does
it like I'm like this shouldn't be
around enjoying life yeah he's a good
advice guy too I call him sometimes when
I need a certain life advice he's always
got good he's wise nuggets of wisdom oh
yeah smart guy and he's he's been
through it yeah and he's got a couple
kids two kids yeah yeah yeah he's a good
egg yeah I wish he was my dad
that's what this all boils now
his last name is Papa yeah that's right
holy [ __ ] everybody's damn you blow up
my bike he was the first big guy ever
opened for too yeah so that was scary
yeah does he murders like people don't
give him his Doom over how he kills he's
got his he's very respected I hope so
but you know I know you mean like like
there's a lot of comics we see just rip
a room apart we're like that person
should be rich yeah you know yes but
like Tom is very respected he does very
well but you know we don't mean to say
that at all but like
we see so many people and I'm sure it's
the same with like actors or musicians
you see someone just tear a room to
shreds and be like more people should
know this name yes and much like you he
has a this positive light about him like
sometimes you go to The Cellar like uh
that guy's there all right he's gonna
tear me to Pieces he's gonna [ __ ] on me
ball busting is is very common yeah as
much as has his place but when you see
Tom or you it's like hey yeah let's hug
it out how about those uh
I'll do a toast it is my toast people to
people who are not a lot yeah
energy vampires yeah they they kind of
uh they just suck from you at all times
their energy sucks yeah and I'm if
you're struggling I'm not saying don't
tell someone I'm not saying don't
confide but there's people whose whole
personality is that oh and then there's
people like Tom who every time you see
them you're just like this dude's just
[ __ ] fun yeah it's like a light a
light yeah there's a lot lightness yeah
there's something exactly and you guys
do a show together so it's like
there's something about that that's like
really I mean shout out to people who
[ __ ] bring that light
a toaster
yeah
we're bringing it back
never went away from me
you're positive I feel like yeah I mean
but I think it's like uh just a natural
demeanor for me I don't know shoot a
pillow no I think at home I'm more just
chill like I'm not like uh Edibles
anything no not really no I I like I
don't know I know I'm very lucky to have
this but I genuinely wake up Pleasant
and wow that's nice and I know not
everyone is lucky to have that that
chemically people were just built
different ways and not to say that I
don't you know wake up being moody or
bad days but I would say my my Norm is
pretty Pleasant don't look at Twitter
yeah right so it's just after social
media for the most part I mean I have to
be on there for work and you know you
don't linger I don't linger I don't
linger I don't I try not to read a lot
of comments
um good and bad yeah so because you want
to see the good but if you are going to
see the good you're gonna see the bad so
I just kind of
some like if someone's like you know
came to a show I'll be like oh thanks so
much so I don't like ignore everything
but I don't dwell on right comments and
stuff just because I do want to be happy
you know I I do want to genuinely enjoy
my life I don't want my entire life to
be wrapped up in this business and what
people think of me here here it's not it
ain't gonna handle I don't want yeah I
don't want my value as a person to to be
dependent on what people think of me oh
boy that's a that's a good advice right
I mean you know to take a lot of that
advice it's because what goes up must
come down you know there you got that
right people gonna like you some people
will like you and then other people will
hate you just looking at you for no
reason that's just the world we're in
now yeah and you can't do anything about
it so why seek out that
you know I think for me I'm like why why
what did I do to that you know you just
start racking your brain then you have
so many insecure thoughts that it kind
of starts validating [ __ ] that you
thought then yeah you go down a whole
spiral I just think it's a slippery
slope you know it's like obviously as
Comics we love to hear laughter we love
to hear Praise as part of our job but I
just don't want to hang my hat on all of
that stuff very much
yeah I mean yeah it's the same mentality
with a bad show I mean you're not as
good as though as the best said you're
not as bad as the worst you gotta kind
of have to keep in a safe middle area
yeah but yeah the comments are right
there yeah you really have to like it's
like right there it's brutal sometimes
you know I been doing this since 2010 so
I've been called every name in the book
you get kind of used to it but you know
what matters is you do these live shows
and the people that come seem to have a
really good time they're laughing they
feel good you're like that's what
matters yeah is that stuff and that's
reality yeah that's right in front of
you you you're seeing that it is real
and it exists comments on the internet
yeah that's a whole other thing it's
common to a lot of people that are
literally like you're in a club and
they're opening the door and being like
[ __ ] you yeah yeah it's not one of your
people exactly that's just a person
who's peeking in yeah yeah I mean I get
like like if I every now and then if
I'll like tweet something that happens
to get like a lot of like you get a joke
and it gets a lot of views or comments I
start having heart palpitations I don't
want that kind of attention you know
what I mean like even if it's like a
funny joke oh God I just I just thought
I was tweeting something like no one was
gonna pay attention
I feel so similar to you guys where it's
like we're entertainers we're trying to
get the laugh we're trying to unify a
room of people and they're just laughing
yeah and I had a thing a few weeks ago
where so I'm in the Omaha Funny Bone
someone screamed up free Palestine after
a Jeffrey Epstein joke I'm like all
right let's let's investigate this I'm
just having fun with the person just
being silly with the person it becomes a
thing gets I posted because it's a funny
clip so it's getting picked up by like
the Jerusalem Post oh really you know
all these like legitimate news sites are
pickling up then so people start coming
at me hard like this guy this guy is Pro
apartheid I'm like watch the video I
don't say that at any point of the video
but people are really but then the guy
saying I'm Pro apart like it's a ton of
repos and I'm like I didn't say [ __ ]
about that I was literally making fun of
someone oh I literally just said you
think the plate do you think the Omaha
funny bone is the place for your protest
like I'm literally just being silly with
the person yeah you can get to apartheid
how do they even she yells out how do
you feel the part height I said how do
you feel about [ __ ] up my show oh
Jesus Christ I'm just trying to go I'm
like literally it's a live performance
that I'm trying to keep funny because
the crowd is uncomfortable right right
wow but that's my that's my point is
like you can't
you can't give them that no because
because that person
so much of the internet is people not
even doing their research and just
attacking yeah that person clearly
didn't watch the clip right that the
person just attacking me and they want
the attack they they don't actually want
reality or Justice or rationality and if
you're like I never said that you don't
listen Nuance doesn't get retweets
doesn't work on social media in general
yes you know it's not it's it's not the
place for that so I don't know I just I
just try to make people laugh at my live
shows and put up silly videos and tell
stories that's the lane that I know and
you know totally it's a good Lane yeah
it makes people happy I I try to you
know put out that positivity and hope
that it makes people feel good and
that's the only thing I can really
focus on yeah yeah I hear you it's just
it's sad sometimes people write a mean
thing and I'll like it and they'll be
like oh [ __ ] I didn't know you would see
this uh uh and you're like what are you
doing like so you just caved instantly
so you don't even mean it like that's
even weirder you're like stick to it
yeah ready call me a piece of [ __ ] but I
think I'm so weak-minded you know that
old Chris Rock joke where he's getting
pulled over and the cops like you stole
this car he's like damn maybe I did
I'm like you're uh whatever a big and
I'm like maybe I am you know and you
start thinking but you're like what the
[ __ ] am I listen to this guy in
Cleveland for yeah but you hate that guy
he not only he's a piece of [ __ ] he's
spineless yeah yeah I know the picture
of him is his profile is just a like a
handgun or something and you're like
yeah always always a rifle an AK-47 yeah
yeah the point of the story is follow us
all on social media and leave a comment
yes we'll read them all of them uh the
new specials on on Netflix uh Good
Fortune Good Fortune oh yeah yeah your
stuff's great I mean it really is
hilarious and uh sweet and Salty's a
great special so check that out check
out your other stuff it's on there as
well you listen on the road yeah doing
some Club dates yeah uh plug some days
you're rebuilding I'm doing like
Huntsville Alabama This Club Ontario
California Oxnard California San Jose
and Irvine all the California clubs
those are fun rooms it'll be like not
too well oh yeah I'm doing like working
it out like um cereal kind of stuff it
was a lot of uh they were coming from
that big Jazz Fest all them all day so
they were just laying there like
they were jazzed up they were Jazzy yeah
yeah yeah
comic comic audiences are so Savvy now
to Comedy like if you go I'm working out
they go oh cool yeah this is interesting
it's the crowd is so sophisticated now
yes well I like buildings stuff you know
in these clubs and them seeing the
progress that that you make when you
come back around oh yeah but yeah I'm
just I'm announcing a whole new tour
that will start the end of January and
I'll be going everywhere again so nice
it'll be busy all right well go go see
fortune on the road killer act new stuff
thanks for coming in thanks for having
me thanks for the the whiskey there jamo
cheers everybody what do you got you
plugging some dudes oh yeah I'm at the
Wilbur in Boston but the joy I'm at the
College Street Music Hall in New Haven
uh The Fillmore in Philly we added a
show Buffalo
uh Cobbs and San Francisco Zanies in
Nashville all kinds of fun they're going
to Hawaii who knew so yeah fun stuff
come on out markdormancomedy.com and get
bodega.com I got Kansas City Tacoma
Spokane on New Year's and then theater
tour in January please come out New
Orleans Austin down Alice Tulsa St Louis
Vegas Vancouver Seattle Portland Salt
Lake Huntington New York AC Royal Oak
Michigan Minneapolis Madison Milwaukee
New Haven Boston Miami Orlando
Jacksonville Atlanta
Charleston North Carolina and Durham
Charlottesville Norfolk D.C Wilkes bar
and Portchester samwell.com
single
I'm very unhappy Bodega catwhiskey.com
uh
great having you here thank you guys I
appreciate it always a pleasure it was
nice drinking with you it was awesome
anything jamo I got a foot in my room oh
yeah pregnant go see the bird oh yeah
she's putting it on zoo I don't know
when this comes out I'd usually do like
Greenwich Village comedy club or
Broadway but I'm gonna definitely have
to take a pregnancy leave at some point
yeah yeah
all right that'll be fun too all right
well I mean Ali Wong
Schumer they've all done the pregnant
shows
all right well that'll do it I think
you're great thank you thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hours
[Music]
we might be true
[Music]